[Music]
you look perfect
fly
did you bleed on the carrots well i died
yep probably
[Music]
happy christmas just did alive yes i
think so
jesus they're early
tony and simon robbed the petrol station
oh what fun
we make tremendous criminals i felt so
good
we're all getting old we were getting
old
[Music]
it's just one potato each just one for
everyone
should anyone watch the queen's speech
well she's clearly in some bunker set up
you know filled with tins of baked beans
and dog food
here's to the lives that we've shared
to our beautiful children
our beautiful friends
may we rest in peace
[Music]
i just think we should be honest with
the kids we know the russians want us
all dead they're sending poisonous gas
to kill us all in the morning it's not
the russians it's the planet it's very
upset
it will kill anything and anyone that is
still alive
we should have voted green
we just want to make sure that you
understand that as your parents
we are not to blame
clearly it's not your fault either
[Music]
[Music]
i've seen the road and there is no way
i'm living like that
[Music]
you